spread is now the number one spreader
about 65 percent of all cases
this is a dramatic shift uh part of it
is the holidays
it's what happens during holidays part
of it
is reduced social options
i can't go to the bar and hang out
i can't go to a restaurant and hang out
uh i can't go to the movie theater and
hang out
come over to my house and we'll hang out
it's just an adaptation of social
behavior to the circumstance
we have a rule in effect no more than 10
at an event these are all the states
that have rules of no more than 10.
people say oh i can't believe the new
york ruled no more than 10.
many states have a rule of no more than
ten
and by the way kentucky just announced
they're going to a rule of no more than
eight
this is a nationwide problem
i understand that people say i don't
like the restrictions i have covert
fatigue how can you say i shouldn't have
more than 10 people in your house
look the truth is government doesn't
have an ability to monitor it
but you want to know what is smart what
is reasonable
what is protective of other people and
yourself
this is where the spread is coming from
it's a small
gathering spread we have to communicate
this now to people
the way we communicated masks
seemingly the safest place my home my
table my family
yeah even that place is not safe
and we're going to have a new public
education campaign that speaks
just to this uh this is not
a government being overly dramatic
these are just facts
and look i've heard the political back
and forth
oh this is a democrats saying this
first of all this is probably the only
issue
president trump's people and joe biden's
people have agreed on
both of their health advisors say small
gatherings are the problem
the cdc under trump
the regulation was no more than your
household
for thanksgiving that's what the cdc
said
so all those uh people who want to say
well this is political i'm standing up
against it
your president president trump his
administration said do it
and joe biden's administration
health advisors said the same thing so
whose politics are you playing if
donald trump says uh the cdc mandates it
and joe biden's advisors say
uh it's smart who's politics
your own politics you're waving the
political flag
whose flag are you waving it's agreed to
by both
it's a fact of being smart and
luckily most of us are smart
i had a conversation with someone over
the weekend
well uh nobody's going to tell me how
many people to have in my house
it's my house i want to have my family
over i can have my family over
i said you're right i still make a deal
with you right now
you do whatever you want in your house
invite whoever you want
but here's the deal if somebody gets
sick
from what you did
you handle it he said what do you mean
i said don't call an ambulance and
expose an ambulance driver
don't go to the hospital and expose a
nurse and a doctor
an 1199 worker because
you wanted to be reckless you handle it
stay at home
and take care of yourself but don't
expose people
and don't ask people to risk their lives
because you undertook risky behavior
oh no no i won't agree with that i said
oh i see
so you want to be able to behave in a
risky way
and then if you get sick then other
people have to risk their lives
because you were risky
is that fair but that's what they're
asking
well i'm going to stand up you want to
be a tough guy
guy being gender neutral i'll tell you
what a tough guy does
go volunteer
in a field hospital in staten island
and help covet patients if you're a
tough guy
you want to celebrate thanksgiving bring
your whole family and your extended
family and go volunteer
in a hospital and help covet people
that's how you celebrate thanksgiving
don't create
more covert positive people and then
expect other people
to come to your rescue that's not the
spirit of thanksgiving
vaccinations that is going to be the
weapon
that is going to be the weapon that will
end the war the only question is when
we're going to be very robust and
aggressive on the vaccination program
we're building it around fairness equity
and safety we're going to have very
inclusive process
i'm reaching out with other governors
to the federal government which is not
now funded a black brown
poor community outreach program for the
vaccine
blacks died at twice the rate that
whites died
uh brown died at one and a half times
the rate
that whites died they are less served
by the health care facilities we need a
special outreach effort
federal government has provided no
funding to do that
there are also concerns with the
undocumented community
that they're not exposing themselves to
legal action
so we're working through that but the
vaccine critical mass
is still months away and until
the vaccine hits critical mass keep
operating
at the maximum safe level we want the
economy open
we want people working uh at the maximum
level
that is safe so to recap it's about
hospital capacity
increase in balance testing keep schools
open
small gatherings are the number one
cause and we have to alert the public
small gatherings are difficult it's not
about government enforcement
government is not capable of enforcing
what you do in your home
but again it's people being smart and
we're getting ready for vaccine
distribution
personal opinion if i have the wager
you'll see these numbers continue to
increase all through the holiday season
probably till mid-january
uh you have not yet seen the effect of
thanksgiving
there will be a lag and you will see the
effect
a week out from today
but i expect those numbers will continue
to go up
so i'm really going out and uh on a limb
i would say guess
you start to see a stabilization
mid-january
at a higher rate raised by the holiday
season
after new year's starts to settle down
you see the rate stabilize but the rate
will be much higher
than it is today that's why it's about
the hospitalizations
you won't see a real end until the
vaccine hits critical mass
and i would wager today you won't see
that
until late spring early summer at the
current rate
could change so uh we have to settle in
but the good news is new york is doing
better than almost any other state
on the numbers uh new york is better
prepared
than any other state and it is all in
our control
it's not in your control but it's in our
control this is all a function
of human behavior and social action it's
all what we do
if you wanted to get the rate to zero
virtually you could do it
if you all agreed to a certain behavior
pattern
we have to work we have to function but
it's all in our control
good news i believe in new yorkers
they did this before at a much harder
level
with less notice and we'll do it again
but we have to do it
we see the gold line we just have to get
there today's numbers
micro cluster areas six percent
statewide without micro cluster four
with micro cluster 4.5 test results 148
000
54 people passed away they're in our
thoughts and prayers
hospitalizations are up to 3 500.
i see you up to 681 intubations
325. tough times don't last because
tough people outlast them who said that
marcia cramer
what's his name your father's favorite
person
aj parkinson you're right
you get the first question because
i've heard aj
at one point
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry
you still get the first question but uh
we have a number of guests who are with
us
on the zoom call and we're going to hear
from a couple of them
uh we're going to hear from ken raskey
and mayor bill de blasio
and county executive ryan mcmahon from
onondaga county
uh we also have with us michael dowling
uh
beatrice grouse who's the head of
haney's the health association of new
york state
county executive adam bellow from monroe
steve balon county executive suffolk
county laura curran county executive
nassau county george vladimir county
executive westchester county
i want to thank them all for all their
help over the weekend
i didn't i would never have thought to
call you over a holiday weekend
uh and bother you but uh commissioner
zucker
said i had to otherwise i would never
have done it because i don't
i don't believe in that you know i'm a
nine to five kind of person myself
uh so thank you all for allowing us to
bother you because the department of
health mandated
you know how that is mike dowling uh but
let's hear from uh we'll hear from ken
rasky
and then mayor de blasio and then county
executive mcmahon
um what do you think ken raske and thank
you for all your good work and b grouse
thank you for all your good work
what do you think about the hospital
situation and what we uh we are looking
at ken
well good afternoon governor i think
you're right on target
uh the hospital capacity issue has gone
to the top of the agenda again
uh the spring was brutal you make no
bones about it
we were all worried about replicating
the situation we saw
so vividly in italy with people lined up
in the hallways
that never came to pass and thank uh
thank god
we learned a lot sir we learned an awful
lot and working hand in glove
with the new york state department of
health with your office particularly
we've come to terms with a lot of issues
that we were confronting
in the in the spring uh such as uh ppe
the stockpiling of ppe you've provided
enormously great uh guidance there
surge expansion and planning including
50 to 100 expansion
this the new balancing uh of within
systems is critical
uh on on the load side of things
and i think that your plan as outlined
sir makes a lot of sense to the hospital
community
uh the new triggering metrics as it
relates to
uh obviously hospitalizations is
extremely important
and creates it is built on a foundation
that uh that we
we absolutely need as we go forward
i'm confident sir based on what i've
seen and what i'm what our
hospitals are experiencing currently
that uh
our ability to uh to cope with this is
going to be a total team effort as it
has been
and uh and our ability to respond to the
needs of the public
including all their health care needs
will be assured by the kind of plan that
you just outlined
so we look forward sir to uh working
hand in glove again with you
uh as we have and uh i think uh
the new yorkers should be reassured uh
that their
health care system is in good hands
well uh can uh
with your leadership this healthcare
system
managed an epidemic that no other state
had to deal with
we had the worst problem in the nation
by far
uh and thanks to you and your
partnership
we managed it and we learned a lot along
the way
so uh we're in for round two uh
with any luck at all uh round two is not
what round one was
and we're smarter and we're better for
it uh but thank you i'm just sorry that
we have to go through it
again but the vaccine is coming and it
will it will end
it will end thank you uh let's go
to uh mayor bill de blasio i know he
didn't get a chance to enjoy
thanksgiving because i kept interrupting
uh but he was very good at uh speaking
with
a mouth full of turkey he he he was very
good
at doing that continuing to eat but do
business at the same time
i respect that you know it's uh you
gotta enjoy it when you can
right but uh governor thank you uh
i thought the conversations this weekend
were really helpful
and i appreciate the plan you've laid
out
and i want to accent the fact that uh
our
hospital systems our health care
leadership
really deserve tremendous praise for how
much they have learned
and the adjustments they've made i thank
ken rasky and
all the hospitals that he represents in
our new york city health and hospital
system and mitch katz and his whole team
at the the amount of
strategic improvement that has occurred
as you're right we we found ourselves in
the middle of hell out of nowhere in the
spring but since then tremendous work
has been done and we're
very different outcomes this is part of
the the good news even in the midst of
the challenge that you
are focusing on today that our hospitals
our health care workers
are handling cases with really
innovative new approaches
thank god we are not seeing so far the
same stress on
our icus here in new york city thank god
we are not seeing
people pass away as we did in the spring
we've got a long way to go and i think
you're right to focus us on this whole
holiday season
and the weeks after but i want to sound
a hopeful note
that i think our health care system here
in new york city is holding
strong for monitoring it obviously daily
hourly
but i like what i see i also like the
fact that new yorkers
are getting tested governor we had
had record levels in the last couple of
weeks
the number of people lining up to get
tested we're trying to make it easier
and set up
more locations all the time the
expansion of testing is
crucial strategy for us all over the
city
uh equitably distributed as you said and
obviously more deeply in our schools as
well
but what we're seeing is new yorkers are
responding
they're coming out and are getting
tested and it's helping us to do the
work we need to do to keep everyone
so that to me is part of the heroic
story of the people in new york city in
new york state that folks really have
gotten engaged
we need them to keep getting engaged so
a reminder of course
everyone coming off the holidays uh that
you need to follow those testing
protocols if you traveled
and you need to observe quarantine if
you don't test
out we're going to be out there and
forced to make sure that people get the
support they need if they need to
quarantine
but also to do the good enforcement work
to make sure people realize how serious
it is so governor
uh thank you uh for the plan you've laid
out we're going to work closely with you
and uh i know that we learned a lot of
lessons from the spring
we're applying them successfully here in
new york city
and you're right we got a couple of
tough months ahead but
you know there's a better day coming but
everyone needs to be part of the
solution in the meantime and that's what
we're going to keep doing here in new
york city
thank you and mayor i think the opening
the schools
uh i thought was the right idea uh and
you're testing in the schools
uh is great so we know that they're safe
and it's that you want to talk about
good news and
silver linings the fact that the
positivity rate is so
low in the schools compared to the
surrounding community
uh so children can get continue to get
educated
and their parents can can go about as
normal a life as you can have
i think that's going to be very helpful
and i think it's going to be very
helpful
as soon as we hit january we get through
this holiday season
so that's that's also uh uh good news
right
amen thank you thank you for being with
us mayor
and we have county executive ryan
mcmahon
from mononga county governor how are you
[Music]
yeah governor i want to thank you for
your collaboration and your team's
collaboration
uh as you know the data-driven approach
to making decisions in this pandemic
is one that both sides of the political
aisle should respect and appreciate
and i want to thank you for that in
addition to that because of the testing
and tracing
programs that have been set up through
throughout new york state
and every county this allows us to have
accurate data so good decisions can be
made
and specifically in onondaga county we
just went from
a yellow zone for many of our school
districts
and some of our school districts went
into an orange zone and what we learned
from the data to your point into the
mayor's point
was that in-school uh testing showed us
that we had a positivity rate
of under 0.4 percent in our districts
so keeping kids in school is safe
the regulations and protocols that your
team helped put forward
are working and as we move forward i
really want to specifically thank your
team
for working with uh the county
executives and the mayor over the
weekend
to look at the orange zone protocols so
we can do it in a safe way
a sustainable way where we can still
address the the testing resources in
other parts of the economy as well
but right now we're very happy governor
we look forward to working with you
as you know in advance county syracuse
basketball
we are in basketball season and uh we're
in the second half of this pandemic we
just got to grind it out together
you're right thank you county executive
and you're exactly right the uh we've
been through the worst
we're not done yet but we've learned a
lot
it is good news on that school testing
and making the testing sustainable and
making sure we balance
so we can hit all the needs on the
testing is going to be very important
but
we'll watch the hospitals we'll get
through the hospitalization
uh issue and then hopefully we start to
turn the corner with this new vaccine
and the next conversation we're going to
have to have is
uh on the vaccine distribution and
making sure
that we do it here in new york better
than any other state in the nation i
want to have the
fastest fairest and safest
vaccine distribution program in the
country uh
and we will thank you for all your time
over the weekend uh
all of you and again i would never
bill steve george mike you guys know me
adam laura
i would never have interrupted your
weekend if it wasn't for howard
zucker making me with one of those state
mandates and it was an unfunded mandate
thank you all very much thank you god
bless you
marcia so governor i have a kind of a
complex question
about a couple of weeks ago you said
that as testing
numbers went up you might have to turn
the valve a little bit
to reduce some functions like indoor
dining gyms
salons and in new york city especially
the numbers are going up almost every
place except manhattan
so is it time to turn the valve a little
bit more
in terms of indoor dining gyms beauty
salons and will
are you thinking of any more orange
zones in new york city itself
here's the problem with the new numbers
the valve no longer
controls the spread
when we started the spread was indoor
dining
large social gatherings the spread now
over 65 percent
small at home gatherings
living room gatherings
and it's an interesting it's frightening
but it's interesting
people adapt okay you can't go to a bar
you can't go to a restaurant
uh what do you do you start to go to
people's homes
and watch the football game or come over
and we'll play cards or come over and
we'll listen to music
we are social beings and when you
close down social venues
it's not that we're going to stop
socializing we'll just find a different
place to socialize
so it's coming from these home
gatherings
uh these states are doing these timids
kentucky went to an eat less
the problem with these are how does
government
really enforce that right
it's sort of like mask weary the only
thing you can do is
educate people and hope that they hear
you when they wear a mask
i think we only gave out you know a
handful of tickets on mask wearing it's
not government enforcement
it's public education family gatherings
uh we didn't do any tickets over
thanksgiving
for people who had more people in their
house than 10 people
it's not going to be a government
enforcement thing
uh you can't control it with a valve
either people are going to hear it
and get it or they're not
or they're not either they're going to
see those numbers going up
and they're going to get it or they're
not
i believe they will because i believe in
them
but this is not something
government can really address with
enforcement that's why i wanted to take
on purposefully
the counter-argument right which we hear
about the
gatherings in the ten oh this is just
politics
can't be politics democrats and
republicans agree
it's the only thing they agree on trump
and biden is this one piece
and the state rule is more lacks
than the cdc's rule well
i think it's tough to show that you defy
government rule and i'm gonna post on
the website i defied government rule
oh really you think that's tough no
what's tough is
going working in an emergency room
working in a field hospital
working with people who have covert
that's
that shows guts and character in my
opinion
uh and what shows character is not
creating a case
for a nurse or a doctor or an ambulance
driver to have to deal with
but it's that's what it's going to be
now it's about
people accepting it and hearing it
in your presentation you reserve the
right to do another new york pause
which in a sense is another lockdown so
are we at
are you now giving up on closing
indoor dining and salons and gyms and
saying
if the numbers go up the only solution
is
a lockdown no there before you get to
hitting the pause button and closing
everything
you can make it have additional
restrictions
uh and an orange zone does that etc
but those numbers are
relatively small compared
to the small gathering spread that's
where it is coming from
once you get past that you're talking
about a few percentage points here and a
few percentage points there
you've given up on restaurants and and
gyms no no no they
are the orange zone has
additional restrictions on restaurants a
red zone has additional restrictions
on the restaurants and the gyms etc you
know we still have the yarn yellow
orange red
are more orange and red zones in new
york city because the numbers are so
high
well as the numbers go up i want to add
to those numbers the hospitalization
rate
because the most critical communities
are going to be those
where the hospital is overwhelmed right
and that's what we want to focus on
remember
ken ruski mentioned italy remember what
we went through like in elmhurst
hospital
right where the hospital was
overwhelmed because that community
overwhelmed that hospital that's all
that happened there
it gets into my well why didn't you
distribute
patient load across your system
we learned that lesson but elmhurst was
overwhelmed from that
community the numbers at that time that
elmhurst happened
are not that different than the numbers
today
how striking is that
do you have those numbers it's march
23rd that week in
early march there was 3 500 people with
covet hospitalized statewide on march
23rd which is the same number
that we have today do you do you get
that
the day elmhurst
uh overflowed let's call it collapsed
the same number of covet people were in
the hospital system
as today 3 500
on both days
but elmhurst collapsed
how did that happen that community
had a rate that was growing that you did
not
notice that then went into
one hospital that hospital
did not distribute across the system
and was overwhelmed
that's what we're adding to the yellow
and the orange and the red
balancing i mean how much do you have a
situation where
it's happening so quickly patients are
so sick
you can't necessarily move them and
you're talking about you know uh
an analogy where this is a war you know
the general will say the minute the
shots are fired the plan goes out the
window it gets very hard to kind of
transfer patients who might be at a
point where they can't be transferred
zach
i've had this discussion at length yeah
i hear your point
this is the argument we had every day in
the spring with these hospital
administrators
until two o'clock in the morning you
have 10 hospitals
you knew the rates were going up
in certain areas among those 10.
uh now you want to say you only had one
week notice
six days notice five days notice you
knew the rate was going
up and rather than letting them walk in
the door
in that hospital when zach came to the
door why didn't you say zach
i'm gonna put you in a van and take you
three blocks away
to my other hospital that has
capacity well that's not the way we
normally do it you know that bureau
bureaucratic mindset whether it's in
government or large hospital systems
that's not how we operate and that's
when we came up with surgeon flex
which is throw the book out on how you
operate
i don't really care how you operate
anymore
so what we're saying today is among
those systems
because they understand exactly what i'm
talking about because we had this
discussion
in the spring everybody said well nobody
told us
balance among your 10 hospitals
today today you have 10 hospitals
they should all be at the same capacity
you know what hospital has the highest
rate of covert patients
because you went through it in the
spring
make sure that hospital and the ones
surrounding it
have reduced bed count now
so you have capacity balance that load
among the 10.
wherever there's a hospital system
surgeon flex
is the next level where the state comes
in
and says to you you have 10 hospitals
you're 10 hospitals i need you you're in
the bronx
i need you to take people from buffalo
because buffalo's overwhelmed
and i'm going to bring down 100 people
from buffalo
that's statewide surge in flex where you
shift among systems which was a
wholly inconceivable concept you know
i'm going to take northwell people and
send them to mount sinai
that's surge in flux northwell
you're going to send nurses to mount
sinai
northwell you have to send ppe masks
to mount sinai that's statewide surgeon
flex which was just an incredible
level that was inconceivable
all we're saying today is we're enacting
that within your network
you must balance the load
and you went through the spring zach so
you know the numbers
it's going to be the same communities
and you've been watching
the numbers go up well we operate each
hospital as if it's its own thing
yeah not not in a crisis you don't
when it comes when it comes when it
comes to using that
when it comes to using hospital metrics
what are the specific
thresholds and data points that a region
now needs to hit
to enter one of the colored zones and
how do you reconcile that with
positivity rates or are we totally
ignoring
going to be in addition to the
positivity rate
those numbers we're going to set this
week
we're awaiting the thanksgiving results
uh and we're doing it with hospital
administrators in other words i don't
believe the thanksgiving wave has hit
yet
uh you need seven to ten days
so i don't believe we've seen the hit
from thanksgiving
now is that going to be harder in new
york city or long island
or parts of erie i don't know
but during this week we'll see the
thanksgiving impact
and we'll be taking an inventory of each
hospital to find out exactly where they
are
in terms of availability because
capacity is
how many beds do you have available
today
how many beds could you make available
if you
load balance with your other hospitals
how many beds could you have if you
canceled elective surgery
how many beds would you have if we
mandated you add 50 percent
uh add all that together and now that's
your capacity
and we need to see the results from
thanksgiving because i think they're
going to be dramatic
do you expect fewer or more orange zones
in the state
given this new layer of using
hospitalization numbers
as part of this strategy like if we were
depending solely on positivity rates
before
and the numbers were increasing there
were more shutdowns on the horizon
but now with us with hospital metrics
being involved
do you expect fewer or more uh colored
zones
well you'll have they'll be different
because they'll be also adding
the hospitalization capacity
our positivity rates are going to be
uh surpassed in a matter of time
they were all a best case scenario
and artificially low you know three
percent just think of the number three
percent
there's no state in the nation that's a
three percent anymore
it's only vermont and maine uh so
uh at one point we have to understand
that they recognize the reality that the
the cases are going to go up i want to
make sure
our number one priority is hospital
capacity that has
always been my nightmare has been
italy uh elmhurst
hospital capacity so that is going to be
added
in in terms of our prioritization
i'm sorry he talked about hospitals
reaching out to retired doctors and
nurses
which happened in the spring in the
spring
you had medical personnel from across
the country coming in
that seemingly can't happen now how
concerned
are you about having enough staffing
as we get into post-christmas post new
year's
that's a great question and you're more
concerned about their shows
and i'm the best
the beds we can
build it's
extraordinarily difficult and expensive
but we can build beds
we can't create more staff
and the staff is starting tired
and you're right we had how many came in
nationwide volunteers
90 000 we had 90 000 but how many were
national versus new york
60 000 outside of new york
how beautiful the american spirit
60 000 outside of new york they were all
busy
in the spring was just us right nobody
else had the problem
they're now busy in their own community
so
that's not going to happen to anywhere
near the same extent
so it's going to be more just our
retired and nurses and i am very worried
about staff shortage
so it sounds like the makings potential
makings of a crisis
how do you manage that
you manage it by raising
the pool overall of staff as large as
you can
balancing the load across the state
and then doing everything you can to
reduce
the spread the
the good news is
we know what we're dealing with this
time in a way we did not know
in the spring and we're better prepared
uh and we're going to be smarter in the
management of it
if you can keep the system balanced
and you don't overwhelm any one place
and you don't have people working around
the clock day after day after day
that's one situation but
uh look crisis potential crisis
everything is a potential crisis uh
unless it's managed
properly right i think we're going to be
fine
here on all of this but
we have our work cut out for us i mean
you can't just sit by
and let this happen
it is a function of action
and that's been the difference between
the new york strategy
and the national strategy from day one
right national strategy was well let it
happen and whatever it is it is and i
don't think it's that bad
denial we were the exact opposite
we were active activists
truth tellers informers
and managers
and that's what we're going to do again
i'm telling people
the way i told them the truth in the
spring i'm telling them the truth now
those small gatherings at home dangerous
creating a real problem god's honest
truth
no political hype no bs
we're going to have a problem in the
hospitals i'm telling you that right now
it's going to be a serious situation
we're going to manage it we have to work
together
hospitals are going to have to do things
that they don't normally do
i'm telling you that right now but
it is it is a manageable situation
and i'm telling you the vaccine
will end the war the vaccine
will not be ready for distribution in
the time
frame you think it is so you have to
recalibrate your clock
if you are thinking i can be
irresponsible now because this week i'm
going to take a vaccine and everything's
going to be fine
it's not going to be next week that is
the
god's honest truth as
i know it and what worked in the spring
and the reason you're wearing a mask
today
is because we told the truth
and new yorkers responded
there was no government enforcement of
anything
that made a difference little bit bars
and restaurants
and i believe the same thing here i'm
going to tell the new yorkers the truth
i'm going to do what i have to do on my
end but i believe they'll respond
how does contact tracing mr
chancellor malactress had his
numbers wrong so let's relish this
moment
for a second that chance so you want to
say mr
chancellor you were wrong i was wrong
who appointed you chancellor it's 30 000
we're out of state
60 000 within the state we had ninety
thousand totals it ended up being close
to a hundred thousand i knew he was
wrong
about thirty thousand a little more i
knew he was wrong
but i was gonna hold it in my pocket and
use it
at the right time anybody want to add
anything
thus far no just echo was wrong
yes dr zucker i just said two things one
is that we understand this disease a lot
better than we did the first time around
and also on the balancing of the system
it's not just covered patients
it's also the non-coveted patients that
they can move
so balancing involves all the other
medical conditions surgical conditions
as well
there's been a lot of reporting that
contact tracers are struggling to keep
up with
all the new cases across the state
especially here in new york city
how confident are you that the state
really has the data to know
where the coronavirus is spreading the
most we have
more data than any state in the united
states of america
that you know is that enough
it's more than anybody else has you have
now done
tests on
we've almost done as many tests
as we have people in the state of new
york
is that amazing we've almost done as
many tests as we have people in the
state of new york
contact racing is not perfect you are
right zach
they don't get uh a great response rate
uh and it depends on whose contact
tracers and
different systems are better and
different systems are worse
but we have more data than anyone else
and at one point it becomes redundant
right you're only testing data on
four sources so
can't identify where four out of five
cases are coming from
i mean that seems like that would have
some a pretty big impact on knowing
whether the virus is actually spreading
and acting accordingly you know yeah but
there's also
what uh what a statistician will tell
you
is you can take a poll of 500 people
and extrapolate what people across the
state
think uh new york city
only gets the results of one out of five
yeah but one out of five
turn out to be a hundred thousand sample
if you know where a hundred thousand
people
got the virus that's a hell of a base
we didn't ask a question are you
predicting that at the end of the
when you finally get the results in from
the post thanksgiving
a period seven to ten days from now that
you'll be making more red orange and
yellow zones around the state
yeah and any new york city in the
suburbs
i already did my predictions see i i
want to maintain the position on
operating on
facts i gave you the predictions
i'll make you a bet on the buffalo bills
if you want but beyond that
all i want to say on predictions is
you'll see a continue increase is my bet
through uh mid-january i don't even know
if the commissioner's with me on that
bet what would you say i'm good with you
on that thing yeah would you
yeah the question is in 10 days do you
expect to name more red orange and
yellow zones
my belief on my crystal ball
is the thanks giving number is going to
be big and it hasn't come in yet
if that's the case yes but we have to
see what the numbers are
let's do thank you um about this
keeping the schools open mayor de blasio
has
offered a plan to have weekly testing
for students
so if those students are in an area that
turns into an orange zone
are they then going to have to close the
school for four days the way the state
has and then
remove them again or can they stay open
who wants to answer that they can stay
open that's something that we worked
through in this more nuanced approach
recognizing that
as you said the mayor's doing testing on
a rolling basis so it's not like if
there was no testing and you would have
to close and assess so they would be
able to stay open uninterrupted
let's think one more yes i had a
question for you um no i mean
from pix11 um you know we can't see each
other over the map
um i had a question in regards to
queen's hospitals
um you mentioned elmhurst these were the
hospitals that were most overwhelmed at
the peak of the pandemic we spoke to a
number of them
last week and they talked about so many
of those hard lessons that were learned
in terms of the keeping up with the
supply of ppe and
additional medical equipment and such
where's the open oversight to make sure
that those hospitals that were really
inundated last time don't
like have the proper supply that they do
versus all the other ones
you want to answer that doctor secretary
we monitor this on a daily basis to make
sure they have enough pp they're
supposed to have 90 days worth of pp
we're tracking that we're in contact
with all the hospital administrators on
a regular basis as well
and also in all the numbers about how
many patients are in the hospital how
many covariate patients in the hospital
what we've seen in the er and on a
regular basis i reach out to the
hospital administrations
uh to be sure that we know exactly what
their problems are ahead of time
but let me give you a for instance what
happened on lessons learned
the ppe these masks
uh hospitals uh they're actually bulky
because they use
tens of thousands of these they were so
available
hospitals just didn't really stockpile
them because you could get them
delivered the next day
from any number of vendors it was
inconceivable that these would become on
short supply
uh a mask by the way n95 that we were
paying
70 cents for pre-pandemic
we were paying seven dollars for
towards the end just think about that
we have since mandated that
a hospital has to have a 90-day supply
of these and everything else
at the rate of the height of the
pandemic
okay so take your high case load
during the pandemic you have to have a
90-day supply of ppe
[Music]
uh and
by department regulation i'll bet you
most of them didn't have a weak
but there was no reason to you know be
like saying to you
uh you have to have at least ten cartons
of eggs
in your refrigerator you know i don't
have ten cards i have one carton at a
time then i
i go and i buy another carton of
the board since you supplies checking
and implementing that mandate
the department of health and literally
that's what the commissioner said it is
it's a requirement they test it they
call
they report it so yes
but that's something we learned now the
problem is you have ten cartons of eggs
in your refrigerator so now you have no
orange juice
but one problem at a time last question
clarification on the numbers thirty
thousand
out of state and sixty thousand in
states
with those with those people on a list
or those people actually came in to help
we had about
forty thousand that were used in some
capacity for nursing homes
and hospitals of the 90 000
off the list and we maintained a central
database at the state
where we helped with the background
checks and everything else so they could
easily go right into the facility
we will confirm the chancellor's numbers
if they are incorrect we will correct
them publicly
thank you guys good to see you i'll see
you
yeah no
neighborhood by neighbor because the the
neighborhood by neighborhood because
well even when you deal with
hospitals it goes community by community
right think of elmhurst
that was community driven thank you guys